a final round of a series was replayed
at the Valerian Champions tournament
leaving the community up in arms about
whether or not Riot made the right call
so what happened and who is to blame
let's talk about it
hey y'all it's Liz just a quick reminder
before we get into this insane timeline
events that we are selling the score
Esports merch you can check it out with
a link in the description below the
valorant Champions tournament has been
running pretty smoothly beyond your
typical Tech pauses that is until
September 13th when fpx are on the brink
of sending X at home it is 11 12 and all
X that have to do is bring it to
overtime to give them a little bit of
breathing room and then this happens
ciao an angel
do the unthinkable here the turret
actually gonna identify Angel where it
deals with it quickly the smoke goes on
Main here look at the burst off this
damage coming in Angel already down to
39.
hey you're in the first one to take the
fight he loses
and the diffuse gonna come through and
this could be the Catalyst of things to
come did you catch it if not let's slow
it down and look at it exit's post plan
including setting up a killjoy turret
for those of you who don't know kiljoy's
turret swings and shoots someone when it
comes into its field of vision but
sometimes if the Lioness say is broken
it will freak out and just shoot
somewhere else so in this case the
turret correctly saw Angel door but with
Angel moving it had a little freak out
and shoots heaven in this case death
continues to hold Heaven most likely
because he has been given information by
the turret that someone is there waiting
that information was incorrect and Def
had a 1v2 after Aaron and second were
picked off which he did not win at that
point fbx had eliminated except there
were people like me very sad that my
boys at Exit lost While others were
happy for fpx who have consistently put
on fan making performances the reaction
were pretty immediate people began
pointing out that the turret made it a
little whoopsy and may have given death
false information personally as a former
KJ main sometimes that's just how the
turret acts but that doesn't mean what
happened was super enjoyable to watch so
while it sucked it didn't seem like
there was anything we could do but move
on that is until we got news that the
round was going to be replayed this was
an official confirmation so we were all
waiting with the round D replayed but
they changed their minds I asked all of
you on Twitter and after 1400 votes a
majority of you said no though it wasn't
overwhelming some of you argued exit had
the information to make the correct
adjustments to bring it to overtime
others argued no that turret gave false
information and that had a significant
impact outside of my poll people argued
that this was normal turret behavior and
FNS responded in kind but all this was
speculation we had no confirmation that
Riot would be replaying that round until
we did half an hour after I pulled you
all the official decision to replay the
round was made I won't bore you all the
vods the replays but what happened was
exit won that round found brought it to
overtime and then lost again so
so I sent them home twice so that was
that the game was officially over more
post-game tweets but now from both teams
with varying levels of emotion and then
that was the game that folks is what
happened with the turret but we are not
done no no we have a press conference to
attend first up was exit just want to
make that very clear up front we did not
at any time at any point in any way ask
for this round to be replayed this was
100 a riot decision I hope that they put
out an announcement clarifying that
um you know I don't think it's fair for
uh you know the players to be getting
hate from Twitter or from this other
team
um you know it's not anything that that
we asked for uh even remotely so we are
happy that Riot obviously uh you know
noticed a bug and allowed us to replay
the round and the match to be you know
played out fairly but you know that
being said I don't want anybody thinking
that it was sour grapes and something
that we asked for in response to a
question asking if fpx had said anything
to them exit described the tension they
were mad at us like the none of us made
this decision none of us even knew what
was happening until 10 minutes before we
got on the server yeah yeah I mean you
guys know me I I say it how it is I
don't really like how you know they were
directing hatred towards us especially
towards second or you know very young
player who uh is going through this you
know process for the first time this
year
um you know it's not fair to to have
that directed towards him and I don't
like the way that they went about it but
you know I understand their frustration
and maybe it's a big indication and it
wasn't communicating to them that uh you
know that we weren't the ones that
called for this then in fpx's conference
they described their anger and
frustration with the decision
specifically saying that there are many
bugs in the game and that this decision
has an impact on competitive Integrity
when artist was asked about his thoughts
I gave my honest opinion
I would fiercely get fined by fpx I'll
be fine by Riot and my career would most
likely be canceled so no comments fpx
were also asked what they were told in
the moment and this was their response
no I don't think it was them who called
it uh so
I don't think we're like to blame about
calling but they can't be not involved
in it right because you can't know
if you didn't listen to communication if
they didn't communicate it how you know
it affected their own
anyway yeah let's just move on yeah we
weren't told like we were just handling
the situation with a bug and that's all
you know so official statement it was
right decision not Etc except it wasn't
an old man and now finally we have
reached the end of this dramatic Saga so
what now well bride has set a hell of a
precedent like both fpx and EXA said in
their press conferences there are many
bugs in this game that impact the
outcome of matches I think Optics coach
Chet said it best there is way 20 bugs
in this game and a ride has set a
dangerous precedent how many times KO
knife not scanning affected us and we
never said anything this is going to be
interesting moving forward artists
tweeted after all of this love how riot
last event confirmed I had 50 Plus
packet loss during around didn't replay
it and then I started teleporting 1211
in the replay round and nothing happens
but a turret shoots a wall and lets
replay the round we are in a universe
where Riot often does not make the call
to roll back rounds which be completely
blunt is in their rule book allowing
them to do so if we were just to isolate
this incident the turret bug I think
we'd go back and forth forever about
whether or not the round should be
replayed I think there are valid cases
for both sides of the argument however
with the greater context of how many
bugs are in the game that they have an
updated list of each tournament and how
many have caused issues for players
without round rollback ride has
essentially made themselves a new rule
that they have to roll backgrounds that
are affected by it to be clear I'm not
telling Ryan to fix all the bugs right
away I am not on that team I have no
idea what that requires I imagine it is
incredibly difficult and frustrating
Wright has made it clear by this ruling
that kiljoy's turret her signature
ability the free one has a bug that has
significant impact by their own logic
You could argue that they should disable
kildre for the rest of the tournament if
it is that serious because clearly in
their eyes it was a serious enough issue
that they brought in players to replay
the round super late at night I do
wonder if they would have replayed that
round if it wasn't 11 12 but that just
might be the conspiracy person in me and
things usually aren't that deep and to
those of you who said except that should
have refused when a tournament
administrator comes to you and says hey
remember that giant tournament you just
got eliminated from well we found a
valid issue we're going to have you
replay that last round you're going to
stand there and tell me that you would
refuse that second chance if you would
that is your prerogative and I truly and
actually mean this I absolutely respect
your decision however it is others
prerogative to comply with the ruling
that has been given to them one thing I
do want to leave you with is a reminder
that everyone in the situation is human
humans with stress emotion feelings all
responding to a situation that they
literally cannot control this is messy
fpx didn't act that Saga may be finished
but boy oh boy right have created a
giant new song for them to sing in the
whole Orchestra is about to strike up
where I'd have to face the music the
entire Community is watching
I think it's a KJ main what you learn is
when the turret does that you just kind
of become acclimated to it and you're
like okay you have to like be very you
have to like really watch where it's
swaying because it kind of like does
this but you know in a high stressed
environment like that it's really really
tricky and I turret guns in my head I
don't know what I would have done I
don't know what Riot should have done
and I'm just glad I'm in no one's shoes
and I'm in New Jersey not in Istanbul